[موسيقى]
لقب المعلم الاول لم يطلق في العالم الا
على رجل واحد ارسطو
فيلسوف يوناني تلميذ افلاطون ومؤسس علم
المنطق في الفلسفه والاخلاق وضع اسس علم
البيولوجيا والميتافيزيقيا ومعلم الاسكندر
الاكبر
ولد في مقدونيا في العام
384 قبل الميلاد كان والده طبيبا لدى
الملك امنتاس الثالث المقدوني جد الاسكندر
الاكبر
التحق في سن السابعه عشر باكاديميه
افلاطون في اثينا واستمر فيها نحو 20 سنه
قبل ان يغادرها بعد وفاه استاذي افلاطون
تلقى دعوه من الملك فيليبوس المقدوني
ليكون معلم ابنه الذي اصبح فيما بعد
الاسكندر الاكبر القائد العسكريه الشهير
ان الاسكندر الاكبر كان يرسل من البلدان
التي يمر فيها نماذج من نباتاتها
وحيواناتها الى استاذه لتسهيل ابحاثه
ودراساته ومن هنا استطاع ارسطو ان يؤسس ما
يعد اول حديقه حيوان في العالم
لاحقا افتتح ارسطو مدرسه لوقيون وقد عرفت
اتباعه بالمشائين لان ارسطو كان من عاداته
ان يمشي بين تلامذته وهو يلقي عليهم
الدروس وظلاه يدير مدرسته 13 عاما
اجتذبت مدرسه ارسطو الكثير من التلامذه
وامست مركزا للابحاث البيولوجيه
والتاريخيه والشؤون الحكوميه والاداريه
لارستو مؤلفات كثيره اشهرها الاورجانون
وتعني الاداء وفيها وضع اسس علم المنطق
كان ارسطو اول فيلسوف في التاريخ قام
باستخدام ما يعرف بالاستدلال المنطقي
لاستنتاج صحه قضيه من عدمها عبر الاستدلال
عليها بصحه قضيه اخرى ومن اشهر الامثله
عليها كل انسان فان وسقراط انسان اذا
سقراط فان
من مؤلفات الاخرى المجموعه الارستوطانيه
المنطق الطبيعه ما وراء الطبيعه
الميتافيزيقيا الاخلاق والسياسه الخطابه
والشعر بعد وفاه الاسكندر الاكبر دبر له
اعداءه تهمه الالحاد فخشي الاضطهاد
والمصير الذي ال اليه سقراط من قبله فهرب
الى مدينه خلسيس حيث اصيب بمرض بعد ذلك
بسنه ومات في سن الثالثه والستين في العام
322 قبل الميلاد
من اشهر مقولاته علمتني الفلسفه ان افعل
دون اوامره ما يفعله الاخرون خوفا من
القانون
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات